afghanistan could be less than a year
away from a 98
poverty rate that's the stark warning
from the u.n development agency as it
calls for urgent efforts to bolster
communities and their economies it says
as the risk of a total breakdown without
international help to keep money flowing
in christine salumi reports from the
united nations
the security council began its stay at
the 9 11 memorial the u.s organized
event included a tour of the museum
documenting the attacks and served as a
reminder of the horrors that led the u.s
to invade afghanistan
but the international community is now
dealing with an afghanistan without the
united states being governed by the
taliban many of whose members are on a
global terror watch list
the head of the un's assistance mission
in afghanistan pointed out that will
require some uncomfortable choices
billions of assets and dollar and donor
funds have been frozen by members of the
international community
the understandable purpose is to not is
to deny these funds to the de facto
taliban administration
inevitable effect however will be a
severe economic downturn
that could throw many more millions into
poverty and hunger
may generate a massive wave of refugees
from afghanistan
and indeed said afghanistan back for
generations
pointing out that the leaders of the new
interim government remain under
international sanctions she stressed the
importance of the u.n in delivering aid
and also in ensuring human rights
particularly for afghan women and girls
nobel laureate malala yousafzai reminded
the council that education is a
universal human right
a united security council
speaking with one voice for girls
education can compel the taliban to make
real concessions
this is vital not only for afghan women
and girls themselves but for long-term
security in the region in our world the
council is currently reviewing the un's
future role in the country the mandate
for the un's assistance mission in
afghanistan expires in just a week while
council members debate the mandate's
renewal they'll be grappling with
matters of life and death including
human rights humanitarian access and the
protection of civilians including women
and girls
kristen salumi al jazeera the united
nations
let's speak to charles stratford in
kabul forest charlie the u.n painting a
very alarming picture of the
humanitarian situation in afghanistan to
what extent has it become worse since
the taliban takeover
well it's very difficult to tell on the
ground how bad it's got since the
taliban took over because of course
that's so recent
but what we do know is that the
situation was absolutely abysmal even
before then
and we know that
billions of dollars of funds
has been frozen by international
organizations
by the us
and of course this is a huge concern to
the the millions of people um who are so
reliant on humanitarian aid in this
country 18 million people
that's almost half the population are
reliant according to the un on some form
of humanitarian assistance every day
i think it's around about 75 percent of
the afghan budget was funded by
international donors so the situation is
seriously critical here and of course
the big sticking point one of the main
sticking points as we heard in
christian's package there is how to deal
with a government
an interim taliban government where so
many of the people in it are on un
sanction lists or indeed in the case of
the interim interior minister on a
terror watch list
it's a it's a great challenge to to get
the money to
the people
on the streets in the countryside in the
provinces who are so dependent on it now
we know that there have been eight
convoys pureed convoys coming through
from pakistan on land borders for
example we know that some small
smaller let's say ngos when you're
looking at the context of the size of
what the un can do
small ngos have been using some of the
domestic airports to try and get aid in
but it is absolutely nowhere near enough
and when you hear the united nations
saying that they expect that almost 100
percent of the population could
potentially be living under the poverty
line in around about 12 months then it
doesn't get any starker than that so as
i say although we are seeing trickles of
aid we are expecting it's
important to say we're expecting another
qatar flight from qatar today that will
be bringing in
aid on that flight we understand and
taking out families with
either foreign passports or foreign
visas in their passports back to doha as
we saw yesterday we also know that there
are other military planes that have been
bringing in aid through the airport but
it is nowhere near enough the situation
here is so dire um yeah aid is coming
through but there is a hell of a long
journey ahead
thank you charlie for that charles
stratford live for us there in kabul
let's discuss this further now with
astrid slatten who's the country
director
for afghanistan with the norwegian
refugee council she's joining us via
skype from kabul astrid thank you so
much for being with us on al jazeera
tell us a bit more about the reasons
behind this deteriorating humanitarian
situation in afghanistan it's not just a
conflict is it
no it's not just a conflict i mean it's
the perfect storm i mean
more than half a million people have
already fled drought affected areas
and they are at imminent risk of
starvation and freezing to death uh for
the upcoming winter in addition this
country is
trying to recover and still suffering
from the consequences of the pandemic
top that off with the collapsing uh
public sector
are the teachers going to get paid will
they resume work
are the health institutions going to
continue to run are the doctors and
nurses going to continue to be paid what
about regular municipal workers
government entity i mean this is a
disaster and the international community
need to step up and support not only
humanitarian action but also uh
lift or or or
peace on the sanctions maybe have
international bodies or trust fund come
in and help the public sector
a u.n conference a u.n donor conference
for afghanistan is you to be held on
monday the united nations asking for
some 600 million dollars
what is your assessment of the current
needs on the ground right now what is
the most urgent thing that needs to be
done
well the most urgent need is to save
life i mean health care must come up and
running the other day i was hearing a
very grave depiction on what will happen
going forward how many hundreds and
thousands of people will die if the
public health factor collapsed
completely um
the ngos on the ground we can stay a lot
spoken the u.n but we cannot replace a
public sector the international
community need to come up with solutions
and they need to come up with these
solutions
the problem right now is that the
international community hasn't been able
to decide what sort of relationship it
wants with this taliban-led government
in afghanistan and i do want to ask you
astrid about your own
experience
working under taliban rule now in
afghanistan how have your operations
been affected since the taliban takeover
have you been able to move around freely
well we had to hit the pause button for
a while because there was so much
uh disconnect between the messaging from
the leadership of the taliban
and and the trickle down to the
commanders uh taliban is a very
decentralized organization
and and we need to sort of restart uh
our engagement um this is not something
new for nrc we have been
negotiating access to taliban for years
and we will continue to do that we are
now seeing from east we are allowed to
bring that female staff to work but
something more have to happen and it has
to happen soon
okay astrid thank you so much for
talking to us about this and painting uh
the the situation there the picture of
the situation in afghanistan astrid
sletten country director for afghanistan
with the norwegian refugee council
joining us there from kabul thank you
for your time